could have another winner's semi-final
on the losers final to meet ultra into
potato but let's not get too ahead of
ourselves
yes you got this loser semi-final in a
minute to
to commentate you know yeah and you know
what you can't get comfortable you know
if you're altering the potato the amount
of times we've seen people win the grand
finals from the losers side you know
it's it's it's happened far too many
times for you to be comfortable sitting
there so uh let's see who's gonna
continue on into this top top three
ladies and gents saudi versus saudi yola
we're going to the howard estate it's
rife versus luffy paul versus jyn
let's see if we can go downstairs and
see some sacrilegious tesco yeah we
haven't actually seen that today we
haven't seen them break all the way down
yeah
[Music]
you know it's just starting off a little
bit poking like you said before these
are two
well i guess yeah literal these are
tekken characters you know jin was a
poster boy paul bin in tekken
yeah
and look at that man like
once again off to a very strong start
yeah just just to reiterate this is the
best of three so it's not um a best of
five just yet after when you get to the
winners and the finals that's when it is
best of three so this is the first or
two
yes
okay
and if you're working on this come back
nice i like this patient from luffy just
backing out that was a big whiff they
could have got something a little bit
more than a jab but you know probably
wasn't ready for that
yeah nice
perfect punish there from luffy
[Music]
lies
was that called hammer of the god right
yeah he uses it so well because it is
plus on on block i believe yeah it's a
great
it really conditions you to not only
that downforce once conditions you not
to duck and then just just
bullies you with the lows yeah
nice whiff punish there
okay down jab wanting to alleviate all
that pressure still like lucy was
getting a bit too much momentum there
yeah
oh
are you gonna do fine am i gonna do
something
dad these guys are on another level
right now man
sometimes because they're in the zone oh
that's a bit okay over with nice stuff
from the range drive wavy wave ooh
these backs against the wall needs to be
very careful uh one more stack could
change the whole momentum of this round
but luffy using those jabs as keep out
round four same print now two rounds up
to one yep very very good stuff there
luffy two rounds in a row now you gotta
get yourself away from that wall though
that breakable wall yes i'm sure race
knows those combos
we've seen so many combo videos where
the people break all three of those
walls and go downstairs as well be very
careful it's huge damage
pretend yeah anyway
lucy pain very patient he does have the
last deficit but yeah you know probably
just waiting for his moment and as i say
wait for his moment he got it right
there but down four two goes to the wall
okay
oh my god what happened there we're
doing some trading places okay go from
backwards and with punish
good break on the throw puts him in rage
now luffy with the life leaders back us
to the wall though trying to get wolves
back nice counter here and luffy and
take the first match and ladies and
gents this is still like first to two
our final first or two of the day
so you haven't got a lot of time to make
the adaptation man luffy was the one who
put him into losing bracket initially in
the winner's side now he's looking to do
it in the losers again here bubsy i
wonder what he got caught hit by i'm
trying to see there's me i'm trying to
do a dissertation in my head trying to
do some theory you know so i can hand it
in to uni like what did he present
before he was doing the downfall one
swayed back down forward one sway back
so i'm guessing maybe it's way back
sizes so maybe try to
do something to track the side step but
i guess jim's got a hole in movies quite
quick so i'm i'm trying to make a
calculation like how he got can't hit
because he just went straight back
straight into the three so
there were some there must have been
some mind games there i'm just trying to
yeah in that situation when you block
down forward one yeah i think the best
thing to do is to size that right and
duck i'm i'm pretty sure right uh it
beats most of the options i'm not sure
if it beats a downfall one sway back
down forward one because down forward
one tracks decision right um so
there's yeah this is definitely mind
games playing out here but we're not
seeing the option stacks that we usually
see from people in that sway scenario
right because if you had size up and
duct and that would have beaten that
that low and you would have low powered
it it's easier said than done yeah it's
100 easier than none for sure like i'm
not saying oh i should have just done it
bro like no of course but like it's it
is something that you can do versus that
way
so we're going to go straight back in i
wonder if this mean a stage change
character chains maybe nope definitely
not character change these guys are
loyalists to their characters we're
going to go to the island paradise one
of the newer dlc um stages i think it
was the one before last
right uh no this was this was the uh oh
yeah yeah this is
the lydia release right yes yeah and you
can see that right now on we've seen the
the beach right we're seeing the beach
then it's like uh i think one of the if
not the biggest uh surface areas of any
tekken stage once you go downstairs so
it's very hard to find the walls even
with the crazy wall carry that we have
nowadays uh with these characters one
thing i can say for sure about this
stage is it's one of the most beautiful
stages man i could do of a beach right
now i think it was a good time to bring
it out you know it's like you know what
come on i might not be able to go to the
beach but i can't at least play on it
right now break this balcony we'll go to
the beach right now
take us to the beach man
nice pressure here nice oh
could have got a little bit more if
you've done the three two that would
have been game
luffy yellow go for it night oh nice
dark nice oh
this is back with a rage drive of his
own that rage drive like is one of the
that hurts like i i felt that in my god
i'm not even playing it's one of those
one that physically hurts you but lovely
parry there right staying composed gets
the parry into the can cans take it to
the wall side look at that why does he
have that move on though
no he needs the wall in it
that's why he needs it he needs the wall
even more
now nice demons poor gets blocked okay
catching him ducking at the wall
oh he's going to the point he's got him
in the corner oh man beautiful i love
the patience there and what read the
timing that timing he's done it twice as
well he just messed with the timing
stayed in his face done a little bit of
movement back left a bit and just knew
okay this is when you're gonna buy it
yeah and that's that's a scary position
you know for rice because luffy is one
match up and two rounds up and he's able
to make a to take a few risks here and
play a bit wild
okay nice about 2-1
nice good job there for the jabs
needs to be very careful because that if
he does if he goes back into the crowd
that's free you probably will count here
maybe that's what you've done before
yeah i might have jabs yeah yeah maybe
maybe
you've got car hit there but he's on the
board now either way arrives trying to
work on this reverse sleep he needs two
rounds in the road to stay alive here
luffy you're not gonna make it easy for
him yeah as we said this is a
first two territory still so luffy is on
set point
oh we're going to the beach oh yes we
are son here we go
okay captain okay nice okay me there go
to the down two
duck there
nice yo seven golden letters right now
one round away from the reverse sweep
has you got that that um tournament
power up where you know you're going to
lose
yeah you need to put all your eggs in
the basket now nice dark could've got a
little could have got while standing two
there but look at this bobby they come
back from right this could be dead and
yes it is no it's not oh my god the wall
is gonna get another perfect did i just
curse it
nice yo
ladies and lads rife stays alive three
rounds in a row it was looking all luffy
but maybe you got a bit too comfortable
with the lead bubsy and just let it let
it slip it's just one of those things
where it's such a dangerous position to
be in like when
do you
keep going with the attack do you
step off a bit it's just one of those
things where when you start hesitating
and doubting and how you're going to
approach this match and approach this
round
that your opponent then you know can get
their stuff started it's so it it
happens more time than often than you
think actually
when people get to that kind of
positioning
yeah it's rough man like luffy's done
this before as well he was up one match
before he was looking really solid in
the in the uh second in the second game
and he just let it slide he let it slide
man so
man i don't know what to i don't know
what he needs to do i don't know
it's one of your poetry sayings that you
said like when someone sees the light at
the end of the tunnel and it's just too
blinding what's happening how did you
say it again
yeah yeah that's exactly it you see the
light at the end of the tunnel and it
blinds you right so you just you just
you just lose sight of the finish and
you just and you end up getting too
cocky you overextend a lot and yeah just
get bodied yeah he was he was that was
his um set point there he was on that
was his round but
to win to take the set but you know i'm
sure luffy you've said this before he is
a veteran player he's he's one of the
best pools in the world
um
there's no doubt he can he can
definitely make a comeback and like
regain that composure
it's all about composing just regaining
yourself just having that little break
you know while the match loads up and
just going back to what was
getting you the wins you know that's the
thing i'm scared of bobby is the fact
that rife when he has momentum oh it's
very scary he's a momentum based player
for sure definitely he's
he's definitely composed but when he has
momentum and if he if he starts this
this round off and gets the win luffy's
gonna have a hard time to make it back
yeah we've seen race just literally run
like just
run over guys
definitely with that momentum and it
looks like you know he's in position now
but no i can't use that parry
okay
range available nice block
oh gets hit by the delay there that
string is that string is one of the best
strings i think in the game just you can
delay it you can just throw it out and
it's safe
wow look at that the side step right
into the duck from uh from luffy gets
the punishment right get up kick we're
going downstairs yes yeah there we go he
gets and he finds the wall still
there you go bam bam get some more combo
still got his backs on the wall needs to
be very careful
okay trying to step out the wall i like
it i respect it it should be very my god
man this is looking all right right now
but i told you buzzy it's all about
momentum can luffy bring it back he has
rage available down four two gets
blocked okay he's pushing him towards
the wall with the rage drive okay nice
cancel knew that would be punishable
i'm gonna go for the low man oh
the string that everyone forgot about
one down three
five rounds straight now for right five
rounds in a row he's one luffy's on the
back foot he was so close to winning
this entire set and moving at the top
did that ripe has him in the corner he
definitely has all the answers now he is
this is when rife is at is scariest when
he has that momentum and he has you
pinned down
and no one's a [ __ ] oh my god great
blood
that's gonna be it six runs straight a
mini pop off there for life luffy will
be eliminated from the tournament after
being up five rounds yeah
wow just six round comeback